I'm so fresh you can suck mine hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to give up to the sequel to give
up one which I played a long time ago
and yes of course I did great at it no i
didn't suck at all i did very good i
didn't give up what are you talking
about please don't check the footage
before yes I'm a baby so I'm gonna
approach this game rationally and calmly
I'm gonna beat it with you the best of
my ability and I tried it out before it
is very similar to the first one and it
has a sassy British narrator oh goodness
it's gonna be so much fun I can't even
remember the last one happened thank you
you're gonna be so helpful I'm not gonna
hate you at all yes I do because I am
much more skilled than before oh did you
I can't believe is so sure I know I
played the first one with you time for
some crushing how about no and they
don't exactly crush when they fall and
explode oh geez
we don't have to be so mean about it as
my intestines go splatter Rooney all
over the walls I am a professional gamer
oh god wait wait my overconfidence will
be my undoing I thought my
overconfidence was the only thing I have
in this world
hop Popo beat you thank you oh oh you
dick oh I won't give up me coward I am a
professional and oh there we go why did
it just oh oh oh come on I can do this
this has got to be easy and oh if I'm
just quick about this I'll be fine
well alright this is gonna be tough oh
okay OOP blah oh ho Bly don't need to
stop on the hoopla I gotta remember to
keep going no oh okay boy there sure is
gonna be a lot of blood on the walls by
the time I'm done with all this why does
everything have to blow me up
blow me down yes okay who was it now who
I'm sure bad one
thank you oh this is gonna be there's
gonna be a challenge
Jesus Oh popping come on I got this I
don't know why it is so hard now
I can't believe another want me to
succeed whoa aah come on
just trying to get down and boogie jiggy
with it
oh I got it like immediately jump to the
next one I got it
why can I not do that I like playing
calm games oh you changed everything the
electrified flooring the electrified
floor fling the seal a lordly fly drew
walling it's not a floor at all I can't
jump for [ __ ]
well freak me whoo-hoo okay there we go
done and Donna
God no I don't know why are so hard oh
come on oh you [ __ ] yeah ha ha ha ha ok
I'm now gonna press the big glowing give
up up well I'm gonna burn I got a dis I
got a dis hey you got it this I got it
this it's just gonna take a little bit
of patience but I know they're gonna add
like guns and [ __ ] well wasn't that wall
wasn't that what you're trying to do
before Oh bye-bye Rhino I love you I
didn't make the jump please don't kill
me
little bitty dooby doo what's over here
it's gonna be something over here that
I'm gonna need probably hope oh now I'm
such an idiot why did I go for that
all right into the tusks of the Rhino
cuz you know rhinos have tusks not horns
while I wasn't looking then so I deserve
to die I guess you gonna be me is you're
here for you you know
in me oh yeah oh yeah I don't think you
needed to train him to kill fats are
normally vicious creatures and things
that do not deserve to have a second
chance
come on why you baby come on you baby
come on you baby bastard good 0:01 now
oh no oh boy oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
oh no no oh I don't care there's so much
lava all I care about is my love for
living and living life and LU not dying
oh I'm gonna get this okay
now I did that exactly wrong I did it
exactly what I shouldn't have done it
mmm I'm such a prick oh come on why am I
such a douche why am I such anywho I
walked right into it I did I did I did
that I did no oh come on what he didn't
even move my problem is impatience I got
my problem is being a deck there we go
there we go there we go I got it now I
got it hey I gave it a goofy
I hate giggle you googly googly great
googly moogly I dare ya it's an
acceptable outcome no you don't know
about that but the internet is not a
judgment-free zone if I were to stop now
I'd never hear the end of it oh boy I'm
home free now I'm gonna make yes I will
oh I don't believe you at all but I'm
tempted oh how great it would be if that
were true my love life is lovelorn and
lon Lauren laughs Lauren Lauren Lauren
Michaels oh whoa whoa you thought you
were gonna get me but then you were
wrong in that [ __ ] I'm gonna die I
didn't die what I thought I was gonna
die from but I died anyway nonetheless
because I'm a dick I'm a dad dick yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah baby oh yeah oh
yeah Rhyno gonna go nowhere fool whoa oh
okay don't go go back go back go back
those shadows are lovely but go back go
back go baby boppity-bop
I did it damn it
in this room okay good I don't know what
that means you're giving up these days
I'm try it well I want to be like the
cool kids
cuz the cool kids they seem to give up
and I ain't a cool kid I'm an ER all I
was about to say I'm a nerd for life but
apparently I'm a nerd for death no fast
looks painful for you didn't care who I
was until I died again
even then they probably didn't care
because I'm just a clone man no why hey
I was able to do that so many times
before I am good at games I am good at
games I'm good at games I'm gonna girl
fire of course fire why didn't have even
think about the fires
well Rhino I didn't even think about the
Rhino [ __ ] mother okay didn't even move
your hand
mmm yeah mmm yeah yeah yeah oh boy I
really want to give up giving up would
be fun on a ball okay there we go there
we go gotta gotta gotta gotta get a guy
to get a guy to get again gotta get
again oh it's stupid and I hate him oh
oh oh why fat why why why why why why
why why why we're on the baby
Wow laughs that's ridiculous this well
oh I missed it Oh God look at me go I'm
so got a games huh
Oh
Oh how about you me you bad bad dude oh
I did not done [ __ ] myself oh okay that
bats are coming that bats coming up
bunch coming oh my god oh my god okay
fine Dodd's this Rhino what Oh miss me
wolf oh hey Willie you can't do that
what do you think you're doing
oh god oh god oh my god oh that's
baloney baloney huh I haven't died there
yet that's cool all right okay okay all
right okay all right okay all right okay
all right okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay all right okay all right okay all
right okay okay all right all right all
right Artie here we go here we go here
we go pop pop pop you miss me Oh God oh
come on what a bunch of baloney patience
is key must be patient must not rush
must not rush okay for them okay here we
go through here
well okay whoa hey whoa oh god oh god oh
god yes yes yes okay I died there but
that's okay I didn't I didn't care okay
just gotta do this again huh it's got do
it again huh well good thing I'm so fast
and expeditious about my judgmental
nation Asst I'm so good at games I'm so
good at games I'm so go to games it
looks a lot more cheerful without my
blood spattered all over the walls why
is there a spike over there I don't like
the fact that there's a spike over there
now I had a better time when there was
not a spike over there well I'm trying
to say I liked it without spikes it's
not ribbed for my pleasure is what I'm
trying to say take so long get back
there you miss me you miss me bad oh god
he's coming back oh no oh no whoa ah no
no no no oh you're so bad I made enough
[ __ ] mad at you freaka frig off
break a leg up piss on poo okay okay
alright
Lukey [ __ ] here boom
Oh God why why is it off rhythm now the
didn't used to be off rhythm why is it
off rhythm now why I used to be able to
do that
let's stiff what's different now [ __ ]
God [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh I'm not a
happy camper
it's a bunch of [ __ ] god damn it
[ __ ] ok whatever really [ __ ] not why I
forgot
god damn it he's a [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] ass
bull piece of piece of piss piss all
[ __ ] you piece up why I was just running
I do that all the time
[ __ ] you oh no no no no no no and no no
no means no no means no here we go here
we go here we go here we go here we go
you'll go boy it will go it'll go we'll
be good it's gonna be so good that's
gonna be good it's gonna be good it's
gonna be good it's gonna be a good one
it's gonna be a good one oh it's gonna
be good oh it's gonna be good oh I can
feel it above owns now oh [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] you
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh look at
this oh [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] pace i shat
whoa whoa pay yeah yeah yeah yeah why it
was open the door was gonna open for me
the door was gonna [ __ ] open right
when I [ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] spinning [ __ ] this is why I don't
play rage games anymore this is why I
don't play them cuz I [ __ ] hate them
I [ __ ] hate them I [ __ ] hate it I
hate it I hate and oh I hate every part
of it I hate everything in life nope
nope no [ __ ] god damn it [ __ ] please
cooperate with me do what I [ __ ] tell
you to do
[ __ ] no no no no no no god damn you ha
fine
oh no no oh oh thank you thank you thank
you thank you for not being a prick oh
hey life you know the thing in the
bottom there's wrong I'm not 45% done
I'm about 90% done with this [ __ ] I
just want to get through this I just
want to get through this calmly and
rationally like I said I was gonna at
the beginning of this episodes means
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] come on please
why that time [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
God Emmitt piece of [ __ ] oh I hate it I
just want to be 50% done I just wanna
bang her gun Wow
[ __ ] yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes I'm
done I'm done I'm done I am done I'm
done
Oh
Oh my throat is thrashed some kind of
sick yeah
all right there you have her everybody
that's as far as my sanity will allow me
to beat it
I got 47% way done if you can do better
best of luck to you god damn it that ho
man I'm like not okay I am NOT okay so
that's all give up two for me I don't
think I'm ever gonna revisit it but hey
who knows maybe I'll drink hot sauce
swallow do that'll be fun huh thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the other rage games that I play down
the description below or in the
annotations over there let me know what
you think of this game please show me
some love and support I just went
through emotional trauma for you guys
though please I took a few years off my
life for you thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you
in the next video good for me the music
stopped wait a minute what are these is
higher than the other god its decision
don't you know everybody Rosie